Neste capítulo vamos explorar
como computadores quânticos e clássicos
trabalham juntos para resolver um dos desafios mais importantes
da ciência: estimar com precisão a energia de moléculas e materiais
Podemos alcançar isso
usando um quantum circuit
para gerar exemplos de estados
que serão pós-processados
e diagonalizados por uma família de algoritmos
nessa família de rotinas
como SQV e SKG, e há um curso completo na
plataforma IBM Quantum dedicado
a eles e a métodos relacionados
Para os nossos objetivos nesta lição
vamos manter a explicação breve
independentemente de você estar usando SQV ou SKG
seu objetivo é encontrar autovetores
e autovalores de uma matriz Hamiltoniana
essa matriz pode descrever a energia de um sistema físico
ou químico, mas o mesmo framework
pode abordar muitos outros tipos de problemas
como logística, por exemplo
às vezes essas matrizes são enormes
então reduzir as dimensões
da matriz preservando características importantes
do estado fundamental
pode ser extremamente valioso — esse é o objetivo no SQV
usamos o computador quântico para gerar um subespaço útil
que contenha o estado fundamental
podemos então projetar nossa matriz Hamiltoniana
nesse subespaço, o que nos deixa
com uma matriz menor que será
muito mais fácil de diagonalizar
usando computação clássica de alto desempenho. Fazemos isso
preparando um estado quântico de tentativa
geralmente chamado de ansatz
e realizando medições para amostrar esse ansatz
na base computacional, o que nos dá
um subespaço amostrado na base computacional
mas o que realmente queremos encontrar
é o verdadeiro estado fundamental. E se
nosso subespaço amostrado não contivesse
todos os componentes necessários?
Se escolhermos um ansatz melhor
podemos obter uma estimativa melhor do estado fundamental
isso nos leva à abordagem baseada em amostras
da diagonalização quântica iterativa, ou SKUDY. No SKUDY
começamos com um ansatz
como antes, mas depois aplicamos alguns quantum gates que aproximam
a evolução temporal de um sistema físico
pode-se mostrar que, com algumas suposições,
isso leva a garantias sobre a sobreposição entre a evolução temporal do
ansatz e o verdadeiro estado fundamental
ambos esses algoritmos partem de matrizes Hamiltonianas enormes
e funcionam de forma um pouco diferente
mas em ambos os casos a parte quântica do algoritmo produz
um subespaço que nos permite encolher nossa matriz
no qual esperamos preservar as características-chave do estado fundamental
então onde entra a computação clássica de alto desempenho
para as maiores matrizes Hamiltonianas
e para as estimativas mais precisas do estado fundamental
mesmo essas matrizes projetadas podem ser bem grandes
portanto, aproveitar capacidades computacionais clássicas mais poderosas
pode nos ajudar não
só a obter resultados melhores
mas também nos permitindo atacar problemas maiores
para unir tudo isso
podemos representar algoritmos baseados em amostras
como uma combinação de diferentes modelos de programação
em um conjunto de recursos heterogêneos
por exemplo, podemos representar nosso algoritmo
como um fluxo de tarefas onde teremos uma tarefa
de preparação do quantum circuit com sobreposição
com nosso estado alvo, seguida de uma tarefa
de transpilação, que requer apenas recursos clássicos
para ser executada. Em seguida vem a tarefa
que usa primitivas para executar nosso quantum circuit
que obviamente requer o hardware quântico
e depois teremos uma tarefa de pós-processamento que por si só
pode ser um algoritmo de diagonalização paralela
rodando em múltiplos nós
adicionalmente, podemos querer executar
um desses algoritmos muitas vezes
enquanto variamos nosso ansatz
ou executá-los completamente em paralelo
com diferentes parâmetros
agora vamos juntar tudo com o SKUDY
no código. Aqui estão todos os nossos arquivos de tarefas
e aqui todos os nossos arquivos de submissão
na tarefa de mapeamento preparamos os circuits.
Na etapa de otimização executamos os circuits da melhor forma.
Na tarefa de execução amostramos as bistrings
a partir do estado preparado pelo
nosso isa circuit.
Que obtemos da etapa anterior
e fazemos o nosso pós-processamento.
Então agora estamos prontos para submeter nosso
fluxo de trabalho SKUDY.
Como você pode ver, tudo está escrito em sequência
com dependências. Vamos aguardar
os resultados e podemos verificar os arquivos de saída.
Aqui está o arquivo de saída da etapa de otimização
onde temos nosso isa circuit.
E vamos finalmente verificar nossa diagonali-
zação.
A partir do agendamento.
E é isso pela demonstração rápida do fluxo de trabalho SKUDY
todo o código estará disponível na seção de texto
ou na descrição abaixo
e é isso — agora passamos por alguns
conceitos e exemplos que podem ajudar você a começar com
o gerenciamento de programas híbridos complexos. Claro
que isso apenas arranha a superfície de
tudo que você pode fazer com a combinação de recursos quânticos
e clássicos específicos. Para explorar mais
confira a documentação e os tutoriais
na plataforma IBM Quantum
e não deixe de conferir os recursos compartilhados na seção de texto
ou na descrição para mais conteúdo
e software. Obrigado por assistir.
Sim.